welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
in the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special confirmed that the collector is
in need very much not on the live after
a purple man with a purple rock blew up
all of his stuff very rude but it
happens which is surprising considering
that not even the gods of Asgard were
able to survive a visit from the Mad
Titan when they tried to get in the way
of what he wanted which kind of got me
thinking where the hell did The
Collector come from anyway and how could
where the collector came from give us an
idea as to why he's decided to dedicate
his life to being the Galaxy's least
favorite kidnapping connoisseur well my
nerd babies I feel like the collector's
surprise hidden appearance in a recent
phase 4 MCU project could hold the key
to understanding what drives the
collector himself but first do not
forget to hit up new rock says merch.com
where you can pick up one of our latest
Obsession shirts or one of our other
amazing nerd options over there I got
this amazing black panther shirt fair so
head on over to the rockstarsbrush.com
to find out because these go away very
quickly all right so pretty much since
he first appeared nearly a decade ago in
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 1. everyone
has been wondering what the deal is with
collector and why the hell he's obsessed
with collecting [ __ ] well if we analyze
the collector's last appearance in the
MCU I feel like we can make a pretty
solid hypothesis and if you're thinking
that the last time we saw the collector
was when Thanos was stepping on his
chest in Avengers Infinity War you're an
idiot just kidding you're dead wrong
though because the last time we saw the
collector he popped up in the Loki
series finale on Disney plus
specifically during the very beginning
of the finale when a mysterious flying
spaceship can be seen flying past the
frame right before all the energy in the
universe gets concentrated into a very
hot to dead State and explodes out in a
big bang that spaceship is the collector
according to a VFX artist who worked on
the show who was interviewed by Marvel's
YouTube channel there are a few little
elements that we pass by one might be
the collector's ship but why does the
collector be included in the sequence
even matter like why did Marvel Studios
go out of their way to include him in
this particular sequence in the finale
well if you've seen any of my past
videos analyzing these black holes in
the Loki finale you'll already know that
I believe that these two black holes in
the finale represents two completely
different Multiverse bunches each with
their own separate safer timeline TVA
and living tribunals which is why we see
canonically multiple living tribunals
briefly as America Chavez and Doctor
Strange tumble their way through to
Earth 838 one Living Tribunal per
Multiverse with the MCU Multiverse
sacred timeline being housed inside the
black hole on the right and a completely
different Multiverse being inside the
black hole on the left presumably either
the fox X-Men universe or even the Sony
live action spider Multiverse or Andrew
and Toby came from and the reason I
believe this is because black holes are
literally what he who remains used to
illustrate the concept of different
universes in the Loki finale if this is
true and these two black holes are
different multiverses then it stands to
reason that the collector is not native
to he who remains a sacred timeline
whatsoever and instead is an alien
visitor to the entire MCU Multiverse
this is significant and makes sense
considering Who The Collector is from
the comics alright guys I'm on camera a
lot so I have to see my face a lot so
you'd think I'd have to put a lot of
effort into my skincare routine but I
don't because I use geology geology is a
15-time award-winning personalized skin
care company recognized in hypebeast
birdie Men's Health Esquire and ask men
grooming Awards with over 6 000 5 Star
reviews that is a lot of thousands
that's six of them and they've recently
expanded to offer products for pretty
much whatever you need all you've got to
do is take a quick 30 second diagnostic
quiz and geology figures out your
routine for you if you need Hair Care
not me use geology's co-wash a specially
formulated cream cleanser that removes
buildup and cleanses the hair without
the big lather or harsh ingredients of
typical shampoo and for the rest of your
shower routine you can use their body
washes that are free of harsh
ingredients smell great and are
refillable and for after the shower
protect your skin from environmental
stressors with vitamin C and Eve for
Rolex serum to keep your skin looking
young and healthy and then a bit of
dermatologist tested aluminum free
deodorant that quite honestly smells
great like I've gotten so many
compliments from the ladies specifically
so and right now for a limited time
geology is hooking our audience ends up
with an absolutely insane insanity if
you use code do rock stars they will
give you an additional 70 off their
award-winning skin care trial set that's
seven zero percent seventy that discount
applies whether you're stocking up for
yourself or stuffing someone else's
stocking instead either way geology has
you covered check out their awesome gift
sets featuring all your favorite geology
products to get started just click the
link in the description take a 30 second
diagnostic quiz and their team of
dermatologists will design a
personalized routine just for you that
ships directly to your door as most of
you probably know the collector is but
one member of an extremely small
exclusive Cosmic Club of [ __ ] called
the Elders of the universe and they are
called the others of the universe
because they were around since the very
beginning of all things however because
their exposure to the cosmic radiation
of the Big Bang all the elves of the
universe have an extremely long lifespan
and eventually learn that they could
never die judging by the Loki finale it
seems like the MCU will take a slightly
different route by having the collector
being revealed as being even older than
the MCU Multiverse itself which sounds
crazy but if you realize is what is
actually happening during this finales
what we're seeing is the collector
basically fleeing the end of his
Multiverse a theoretical Cosmic event
that NASA scientists predict will happen
at the end of our universe called the
big cry Crush when all the energy in the
universe gets concentrated to a single
super tiny and super compressed hot Bend
State to prepare for the next big bang
where the universe is born Anew and if
you remember from my video on why the
collectors sold nowhere Benicio del Toro
himself revealed that the reason why the
collector collects is because he forces
a coming Calamity in the cosmos and that
he needs to preserve various pieces of
flora fauna and irreplaceable items like
Noah and the flood because of This
calamity coming The Collector has been
collecting for a long time species of
all manners antiques everything he's
kind of like Noah from Noah's Ark he
believes that there's going to be a big
catastrophe in the galaxy and the whole
universe and he's collecting all these
creatures to preserve them somehow so
there's an element of altruism but his
ways of collecting might not be the best
ways I firmly believe that the collector
is preparing for the next big crunch
coming to the MCU because he barely
escape the destruction of his own native
Multiverse and he knows that it is an
inevitable part of the cosmic cycle of
every Multiverse and even though he is
literally forcing thousands of beings to
live in prison for the rest of their
lives at the end of the day the
collector is actually trying to save
them from the inevitable coming Cosmic
apocalypse so he's basically right but
that is it that is where the collector
came from he is not native to the MCU he
is from another Multiverse altogether
what do you guys think let us know in
the comment section below thank you guys
so much for watching this video you can
follow me at Master chamin on Twitter if
you want to see me tweet some weird [ __ ]
and amazing theories more importantly
you can follow new rockstars wherever we
are on social media and of course do not
forget to hit up new roxasmarch.com
where you can get a cool shirt like this
or any other of our awesome nerd options
over there I love you guys so much and
I'll see you guys later goodbye